non
[Musique]
la maison du parc c'est effectivement le
coeur du parc naturel régional de la
brenne
c'est un petit peu le passage
incontournable quand on arrive en bref à
l'année on a à peu près 70 mille
visiteurs mais
je dirais sur une partie du paysage
extrêmement ouvert à la fois
caractéristique est essentiel pour la
prime
le parc naturel de la brenne a été créée
dans les années 90 en plein coeur d'un
territoire très identifié par ses étant
très vite la maison du parc est devenu
la porte d'entrée de sa découverte par
les touristes
édifié dans un ancien domaine agricole
typiques de cette région
elle rassemble une quarantaine de
personnes qui oeuvrent à remplir toutes
les missions qui lui sont pour vous la
préservation environnementale bien sûr
mais aussi l'activité économique et
humaine de son territoire
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ces
hommes et de ces femmes qui jour après
jour mais toute leur énergie
après rayonner le territoire pour la
découverte de la réserve
alors il me reste trois places
c'est 8 euros par personne donc ça dure
deux heures à peu près où et vous
règlerez sur place justin est l'une des
trois permanente qui anime l'accueil à
l'entrée de la boutique de la maison du
pain c'est un petit peu le passage
incontournable on va dire quand on
arrive en brenne pour avoir les
informations sur les revenus sur sont ni
avoir à faire et c'est à l'année on a à
peu près 70 mille visiteurs
donc la saison aujourd'hui à s'est
allongée en fait c'est là qu'on a
à partir de là un petit peu avant pas
que jusqu'à la toussaint on a vraiment
du monde constamment ouvert toute
l'année donc déjà on a des demandes
aussi qui varient en fonction des
saisons
donc c'est là aussi que ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'on va rencontrer
vraiment différent des personnes sur des
mondes vraiment vraiment varié nous on a
un autre travail aussi un petit peu
l'hiver puisque on a un petit peu moins
de monde on travaille sur la partie
documentation donc touristique on
prépare la saison suivante avec tout le
contact avec les prestataires etc
c'est vraiment vraiment varié en fait en
été il n'est pas rare de voir plus de
300 personnes dans la journée
sans oublier les nombreux appels
téléphoniques ici être polyvalent est
indispensable justin tiennent aussi la
caisse pour venir en aide à marica qui
gère la boutique alors ombre je ne
parlais pas ça c'est de ma faute et
autrichiennes ne parlait pas ça vous
avez combien de producteurs
[Musique]
alors je dirais à peu près 120 à tour
des entre entre 100 et 120 tout compris
les nombreuses références je dirais
plutôt à tour des du mille d'entre 2000
et 3000 le réassortiment est fait par
les producteurs
il n'y a pas de stockage autant dire
qu'il faut être vigilant et réactif pour
ne pas retrouver les étagères on sait
jamais quand la libration arif et
parfois ça peut rêver tout en même temps
comme c'est arrivé il y a des jours où
ça pue qu'est ce qui pèse pas livrés et
ses riffs
un coup comme scout c'est vraiment un
petit peu compliquées à prévoir
marica qui possède davantage de parler
plusieurs langues s'occupe également
d'accueillir les visiteurs
come on
c'est pour les clôtures on fera comme
l'an dernier enfin une réunion avec
l'ensemble des cinq exploitants et puis
on convoquera le prestataire pour faire
le point sur sur chacun des segments
mais c'est vrai une que cette année la
priorité c'est vraiment tout ce qui doit
se construire autour de pissotière ou de
de foucault en termes de clôture vincent
et thibaut font partie de ceux qui sur
le terrain veille au patrimoine naturel
géré par le passé étant s'est
effectivement les étangs qui sont
caractérise je dirais la richesse la
biodiversité de la brenne mais il ne
faut pas oublier les prairies puisque
dans certaines d'entre elles on peut
rencontrer plus de 80 plantes à fleurs
différentes
et quand on a une grande variété de
plantes on a évidemment une grande
variété de faune notamment d'insectes
donc toute l'activité agricole sur cette
réserve naturelle est absolument capital
au bon maintien de la biodiversité le
parc naturel régional de la brenne à
plusieurs missions dont celle de la
protection de la nature et de la
préservation de son patrimoine naturel
pour ce faire on est une équipe d'une
quinzaine d'agents avec des missions
à ces différentes mais qui se recroisent
de toute façon est une autre grande
licence et l'accueil du public
l'accueil du public justement thibault
aujourd'hui à son programme une
permanence à la maison de la nature la
partie du travail à la maison de la
nature ça consiste à prolonger les le
côté pédagogique de la réserve où on
accueille le public
la maison de la nature ont fait
principalement de l'accueil naturaliste
pour faire découvrir la nature aux
visiteurs en brenne les oiseaux reptiles
amphibiens présenter les différents
sites où ils peuvent aller observer
toutes ces espèces là sur l'année je
passe au moins la moitié de mon temps à
l'extérieur était comme hiver au chaud
comme au froid c'est c'est toujours
plaisant on voit toujours une grande
diversité au niveau des paysages en
fonction de la lumière en fonction de
l'heure et des saisons
sur ce territoire les néophytes côtoient
les ornithologues chevronnés à la
recherche de l'oiseau rare
[Musique]
on
au parc on les appelle les gars la
brigade sont quatre ils travaillent en
équipes de deux leur mission la lutte
contre les espèces envahissantes leur
terrain de jeu les étangs du parc privé
ou public
ce matin ils partent ramasser les nas ou
espère t-il
les écrevisses rouge louisiane véritable
fléau pour le milieu aquatique se seront
fait piéger voyez tous les grappes une
femelle peut porter jusqu'à 600 e et il
peut pondre deux fois dans l'année donc
ça peut aller vraiment très très vite on
assure du piégeage sur un certain nombre
des temps tout au long de l'année donc
c'est une mission permanente donc avec
des passages réguliers au moins une à
deux fois par semaine parfois plus selon
la souvent les cycles donc c'est
vraiment ça le coeur le 15 mars par la
mission la brigade a été constituée en
priorité pour cette espèce là n'est pas
non plus à l'abri d'en trouver sur les
routes dans les prairies dans les fossés
vraiment rien la reppe l'écrevisse de
louisiane
elle peut parcourir des kilomètres en
plusieurs jours même en dehors de l'eau
elle résiste vraiment très très
facilement l'équipe intervient depuis
deux ans sur cet étang avec un certain
succès mais l'équilibré reste très
fragile et dépendante des milieux
alentours c'est pourquoi les
propriétaires d'étangs peuvent faire
appel à la brigade brigade espèces
exotiques envahissantes et toujours sur
le terrain donc avant d'intervenir ou
faire quoi que ce soit ou juste pour
vérifier les propriétaires nous appelle
on intervient et soit on met en place
après une action de gestion où on leur
conseille certaines choses où on leur
prête du matériel aussi ça c'est
possible
aujourd'hui aurélie et simon auront
amassé 21 écrevisses dans les nasses
après les avoir détruites comme la loi
les y oblige une note soigneusement sur
leurs carnets les chiffres pour leurs
statistiques
grâce à cette action en deux ans la
population d'ecroville de cet étang n'a
pas augmenté
[Musique]
a priori rien ne distingue cette salle
d'une auberge de campagne pourtant le
restaurant de la maison du parc à ses
particularités
il est géré par une association depuis
sa création il ya même trois ans sur une
des toutes seules on ne voulait pas de
restauration traditionnelle pour pas
concurrencer les restaurateurs locaux et
donc il m'est venue l'idée de faire des
tartines pour présenter les produits
locaux
bon là voyez je suis en train de faire
la une tartine de saison avec les
légumes légumes qui viennent du seat et
à côté avec qui on travaille voilà huit
personnes travaillent habituellement ici
un chiffre qui peut doubler pendant la
période estivale il faut dire que
l'établissement rencontre un vrai succès
sur une année nous sommes autour à 24
milles couverts le midi ce qui
représente à peu près 65 couverts par
jour
nous travaillons 16 heures sur cette
voie pas le jour de noël et jour de
longues nous sommes fermés et après cela
les dernières pour 2016 nous avons fait
vingt-cinq mille crêpes qui sont servis
elle dans l'après midi comme à la
boutique la polyvalence est de mise
en contrepartie des aménagements
d'horaires et de planning and travaille
depuis 14 ans
ici c'est vrai qu'on travaille pas le
soir donc on a une qualité de vie quand
on est dans la restauration
effectivement avoir une famille
travaille en restauration travail et
demi dit faire la coupure reprendre le
soir c'est assez compliqué après quand
on a des enfants
jean louis a fêté ses 18 ans de présence
il est le seul à avoir un diplôme de
serveurs avec le chef pâtissier
c'est familial mais familial sauf que
quoi y ait du monde allait plus voilà la
c
et ça tourne familiale ou pas là il ya
plus de il faut et professionnels
en cuisine le chef a attaqué la
confection des frites de carpes il se
mange 100 kg par semaine en été
l'automne pointe le bout de son nez et
en salle les clients sont toujours
nombreux le dimanche
il est impératif de réserver en toute
saison
on
le parc naturel régional rayonne sur un
territoire qui a une forme d'homogénéité
il forme de cohérence et c'est vrai
qu'il y à un certain nombre de sujets de
thématiques qui n'étaient pas portés par
les collectivités territoriales
intermédiaire n'est communes ou les
communautés de communes donc thématiques
et sujets qui ont été pris en charge
très naturellement par le parc naturel
régional de la brenne c'est vrai dans le
domaine de la santé c'est vrai dans le
domaine culturel
c'est vrai dans le domaine de la petite
enfance christelle est l'une des deux
musiciens employé par le parc pour
apporter aux enseignants qui en font la
demande leur expertise
c'est son point d'attaché la maison du
parc son champ d'activité s'étend sur
toutes les écoles du territoire
bonjour moi je m'appelle kristen wiig et
il ya des enfants que je connais ya
plein d'enfants je ne connais pas on
s'est vu l'année dernière je suis venu
faire de la musique avec les autres
enfants qui sont séduits
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée pour elle
dans l'école de renaix pendant un
semestre elle viendra chaque semaine
animé un atelier qui servira de support
pédagogique aux comptes l'effort c'est
vraiment une aide parce que la musique
fait partie du programme scolaire c'est
aussi une aide de quelqu'un de
spécialisé pour les enseignants et les
enfants bien sûr mais c'est pas nous
pour créer des musiciens ce sont les
élus du parc qui ont un jour mais au
programme cette animation à destination
des enfants du territoire pour le plus
grand plaisir de nous
à jamais
on n'a jamais
déjà
vingt mille fourmies à moi monté en taxi
la cinquantaine de parcs naturels
régionaux existants en france sont tous
différents et mènent des politiques de
territoire adaptés à leurs
particularismes
mais la brenne en prenant en compte les
besoins de sa population et
singulièrement de ces jeunes à créer une
dynamique suivi aujourd'hui par d'autres
structures un sap en tête
[Musique]
avec cinq états